a public DNA database led to an arrest
for a cold case from more than two
decades ago
Angie Dodge was murdered in Idaho Falls
back in 1996 but police could not find
her killer
despite having a sample of his DNA then
in 2014 investigators made the
controversial decision to search a once
public DNA base owned by ancestry.com
and Murray Green investigates for this
week's 48 hours she's been following
this case with 48 for more than two
years my name is Carol dodge and I am
the mother of Angie dodge who was
brutally murdered in June of 1996 for 23
years I've traveled every Road there is
to find justice for my daughter
when her daughter Angie was first
murdered Carol dodge thought the killer
would be brought to justice quickly
Idaho Falls police had his DNA a
pristine sample says DNA expert Greg
Campion it's a single profile complete
identification one man to the exclusion
of everyone on the planet but for nearly
two decades police couldn't find a match
to the DNA not even in the criminal
database so in 2014
Carol Dodge pushed then case detective
Patrick McKenna to do something very
controversial search public DNA
databases in search of the killer or
anyone related to him my whole purpose
is to find who killed Angie Dodge
detectives searched a small database
owned by ancestry.com which used to be
public and got a hit it led us to this
michael essary jr. who just happened to
be a filmmaker Michael asuri was living
in New Orleans Louisiana trying to break
into the film industry
I shove your body over in the shower I
just kept stabbing her with this short
film called murderabilia murderabilia
got me the reputation of being a person
who is really into murder and things
like that police picked us reopening and
collected his DNA they finally had to
look at me and go no we think that you
Michael luxury you know we think that
you're involved in this murder case
uhsorry turned out not to be the killer
but in the end the man who did match the
DNA was actually a distant relative us
Reid didn't even know existed a man who
in 1996 was living just across the
street from Angie dodge green joins us
at the table all these years later you
can still feel in here Carroll dodges
pain can police still use ancestry.com
no well so this was long before we had
heard about familial DNA and the Golden
State killer and some other cases that
have been solved so ancestry was sort of
caught off guard by this they say now
cuz we reached out to them that police
cannot use their DNA database anymore
unless there is a court order or a
warrant the database that was used in
this case was public at the time they
have shut it down they have made it
private so no one can access it alright
and Murray thank you very much and you
can see Anne Murray's full report the
twisted case of Angie Dodge on 48 hours
tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central right
here on CBS